libro che vi cito è dune che non so se
conoscete è un libro del 1950 65 di
frank herbert e la citazione che vi
leggo è questa cercò il tubo della sua
tuta di stillante fissato al collo e
inghiottiva un sorso d'acqua
pol penso che in quell'attimo lui
diventava realmente un uomo di arrakis
vivendo dell'umidità del proprio corpo
del proprio respiro
l'acqua era insipida magli calmò
l'arsura ora per chi tra voi non lo
conoscesse arrakis è un pianeta è un
pianeta lontano che chiaramente esiste
in questo universo creato dalla penna di
herbert ed è un pianeta molto inospitale
coperto per la totalità della sua
superficie da deserto
gli abitanti di questo pianeta per la
loro sopravvivenza sono costretti quindi
a indossare degli indumenti molto
tecnologici che si chiamano tutte di
stillanti che cosa fa una tuta di
stillante intanto una tuta di stillante
qualcuno cioè david lynch nel film
nell'adattamento cinematografico del
romanzo di herbert se l'ha immaginata
così come la vedete nell'immagine è una
tuta di stillante è un indumento che è
in grado di riciclare
il calore corporeo trasformandolo in
acqua il calore corporeo e anche le
urine e immagazzinare l'acqua in delle
tasche in maniera tale che chi indossa
poi questa tuta possa avere direttamente
da queste tasche e garantendosi quindi
una lunga autonomia anche in un pianeta
così ostile
ora l'idea diciamo da cui parte herbert
nella realizzazione di questo romanzo è
quella di un uomo che chiaramente e può
anche adattarsi alla vita in ambienti
molto ostili ma sicuramente deve avere a
disposizione l'acqua è abbastanza
scontato se ci pensiamo
e c'è un'altra lezione però se volete
nascosta in questo in questo libro un
altro messaggio ovvero che l'adattamento
dell'uomo all'ambiente richiede anche
degli sforzi da un punto di vista
scientifico e tecnologico per utilizzare
al massimo quello che sia già a
disposizione
il progetto di cui vi parlo stasera è il
progetto perseo che ha immaginato di
utilizzare l'acqua quindi una risorsa
che sicuramente l'uomo nella futura
esplorazione umana dello spazio dovrà
avere per un uso diverso dal solito
quindi non soltanto acqua come riserva
per bere ma acqua come possibilità di
schermare gli astronauti dalla
radiazione per sel sta per personale la
dsm silli infor interplanetari missioni
che vuol dire appunto protezione
personale dalla radiazione in viaggi
interplanetari e il perseo che tutti
conosciamo
all eroe mitologico che è stato in grado
con uno scudo di schivare lo sguardo
pietrificante di medusa nel nostro
progetto
perseo sostanzialmente si difende con
uno scudo come lo vedete nel logo del
progetto si difende con lo scudo sullo
scudo guardate bene ci ha disegnato una
molecola d'acqua e si difende con questo
scudo dai raggi del sole
quindi l'idea è proprio questo a
realizzare un indumento per astronauti
pieno d'acqua che grazie al contenuto
d'acqua possa proteggerli nel caso di
tempeste solari attorno al logo vedete
tutti i nomi dei partner del progetto e
questo disegno è anche quello che poi è
come vi farò vedere tra un attimo è
stato realizzato e cucito come patch
sulla giacca sul prototipo di giacca che
abbiamo effettivamente realizzato e
testato in orbita ma questo ve lo
racconto tra un attimo quello che ci
serve capire è perché innanzitutto il
nostro perseo si deve schermare dal sole
per questo è necessario fare una piccola
premessa quella che vedete in figura è
una rappresentazione artistica diciamo
dell'ambiente di radiazione nello spazio
interplanetario
abbiamo sentito parlare stasera di
particelle particelle per curare tumori
ecco le stesse particelle e particelle
molto più pesanti quindi non solo
protoni carboni ma anche ai nuclei di
elementi davvero più pesanti fino al
ferro e all'uranio sono liberamente in
viaggio nello spazio interplanetario e
come vedete queste particelle sono
liberamente in viaggio p che non trovano
materia con la quale interagire quindi
sulla terra sulla superficie della terra
noi siamo così fortunati da avere
l'atmosfera che questo involucro gassoso
trattenuto dalla forza di gravità
esercitata dal pianeta che ci protegge
da questo flusso continuo di radiazione
che ci arriva dallo spazio nello spazio
profondo ai nostri astronauti in viaggio
sono invece più facilmente raggiunti da
questa radiazione o dalla radiazione che
si genera quando quelli che si chiamano
i raggi cosmici vanno a colpire ad
esempio le pareti dei veicoli spaziali
questa fonte di radiazioni
nello spazio aumenta il rischio di
conseguenza è la salute degli astronauti
e vi parlo di conseguenze a lungo
termine significa cioè che l'astronauta
una volta conclusa la missione è tornato
a terra nel corso degli anni che gli
restano per godersi appunto il meritato
riposo sulla superficie del nostro
pianeta può manifestare degli effetti
legati all'esposizione che ha subito
durante il viaggio interplanetario
parlo di incidenza aumentata di tumori e
parlo di danni alla vista di danni al
sistema cardiocircolatorio di danni al
sistema nervoso centrale
ora questo tipo di esposizione e vi
dicevo un esposizione cronica e
prolungata che esiste per tutta la
durata della missione dell'astronauta
nello spazio
oltre a questa fonte però di radiazione
con cronica
c'è una fonte di radiazione altrettanto
se non più pericolosa che è dovuta a
fenomeni solari e qui torniamo al nostro
perseo che si difende dal sole
come vedete nella slide dal sole possono
partire delle vere e proprie tempeste
che consistono in missioni nello spazio
interplanetario di grandissime quantità
di particelle principalmente protoni
questi fenomeni sono imprevedibili molto
difficili anzi da prevedere in larga
parte in ritardi appunto non possiamo
farci nulla
e il nostro obiettivo era proprio quello
di fornire agli astronauti uno strumento
per essere in grado di difendersi in
queste situazioni di emergenza ovvero
quando accadono questi fenomeni e gli
astronauti si trovano in orbita
ora i quali sono le conseguenze intanto
di fenomeni di questo tipo
un'esposizione da una dose acuta da
radiazioni può causare diversi danni
alla salute che possono essere a
differenza di quelli che citavo prima
dei danni immediati o a breve termine
quindi nel corso della durata della
missione in particolare come vedete in
questa rappresentazione
esistono molti tipi di tessuti e organi
che sono sensibili all'insorgenza di
questi effetti ma tra tutti il tessuto
l'organo diciamo sicuramente più
sensibile e che dobbiamo preoccuparci
maggiormente di proteggere è il midollo
osseo in particolare nella sua
componente di midollo rosso che quello
responsabile della produzione delle
cellule del sangue ora un astronauta
esposta una dose acuta dal vento solare
può manifestare dei sintomi immediati
quali nausea spostamento vomito ma
soprattutto in caso di gravi danni al
midollo rosso a questa dose può
rivelarsi persino letale uno degli
esempi che storicamente più citati in
termini di tempeste solari e una
tempesta solare che c'è stata
nell'agosto del 72 ed è molto eccitata
semplicemente perché
è stata la grande tempesta solare un
grande evento di particelle solare ed è
occorso tra due missioni apollo tra la
missione apollo 16 e la missione apollo
17 quindi la missione apollo 16 aveva
appena fatto ritorno sulla terra
nell'aprile del 72 e la missione apollo
17 invece aveva l'allunaggio previsto in
dicembre dello stesso anno quindi dalle
ricostruzioni che sono state fatte se un
astronauta si fosse trovato sulla
superficie della luna durante la
tempesta dell'agosto del 72
probabilmente la dose di radiazione
sarebbe stata una dose letale specie in
assenza delle cure mediche
immediatamente disponibili sulla terra
quindi quello che mi potete chiedere a
questo punto è che cosa possono fare gli
astronauti al giorno d'oggi per
proteggersi dalle tempeste solari
la vera verità è che non possono fare
molto se non nascondersi o meglio
diciamo rifugiarsi in alcune zone del
loro ambiente di vita spaziale che sono
state costruite con uno spessore
aumentato delle loro pareti quindi
sostanzialmente negli ambienti di vita
spaziali è previsto che esistano dei
rifugi in cui gli astronauti possono
andare a rifugiarsi a nascondersi e
possano trascorrere all'interno di
questi spazi tutta la durata dell'evento
o almeno quelli che si chiamano le ore
di flusso peggiore quindi le ore
dell'evento in cui il flusso di queste
particelle è più elevato
capite bene però che appunto per limiti
tecnici se volete di massa di
disponibilità di massa al lancio e per
limiti tecnici di costruzione di questi
ambienti di vita spaziale
molto spesso ci si riduce ad avere dei
piccoli rifugi dei rifugi davvero troppo
piccoli per far sì che gli astronauti ci
possano passare molto tempo perché
questi tempeste solari possono durare
ore come possono durare giorni
l'altro grosso problema s l'astronauta
nel corso della tempesta solare è nel
rifugio ma deve improvvisamente
per motivi emergenziali uscire perché
dovrebbe mai voler uscire ad esempio
perché la tempesta solare in quanto
aumentato il flusso di radiazione può
anche danneggiare l'elettronica del
veicolo spaziale e quindi l'astronauta
ad esempio ha necessità di uscire per
riavviare l'elettronica danneggiata
quindi il nostro progetto il progetto
perseo si proponeva in qualche modo di
fornire una soluzione al dilemma
dell'astronauta esco non esco cosa
faccio se devo proprio uscire tanto vale
che mi protegga con cosa posso
proteggermi ma è qui che torna in gioco
l'acqua torna in gioco l'acqua perché
l'acqua sicuramente ci sarà ci sarà e
accompagnerà l'uomo in tutta
l'esplorazione umana dello spazio sarà
una risorsa sempre a disposizione
quindi l'idea che abbiamo avuto e che ci
ha portato alla realizzazione del primo
prototipo è quella per l'appunto di
vestire l'astronauta con l'acqua da qui
l'astronauta destra acqua quindi
l'astronauta cosa può fare in questi
casi poi indossare un dispositivo come
quello che vedete che ha un primissimo
prototipo molto semplice molto
rudimentale se volete che ha una giacca
che abbiamo costruito perché si potesse
riempire con l'acqua potabile della
stazione spaziale internazionale
la giacca per come la vedete è
costituita da quattro contenitori
d'acqua 2 sulla schiena dell'astronauta
e due sulla parte frontale del gusto
dell'astronauta questi contenitori
d'acqua una volta pieni assumono uno
spessore di 7 centimetri per un totale
per i quattro contenitori di 22 litri
d'acqua quindi l'astronauta con questi
22 litri d'acqua addosso può proteggersi
dalla radiazione perché tra la
radiazione e i tessuti sensibili
dell'astronauta si frappongono ulteriori
sette centimetri d'acqua che
costituiscono una buona schermatura una
schermatura aggiuntiva rispetto a quella
delle pareti dell'ambiente di vita
spaziale in particolare nel caso appunto
delle tempeste solari
ora tutto questo è chiaramente molto
bello sulla carta ci serviva però la
possibilità di testare in orbita un
dispositivo di questo tipo
perché se ci pensa altre stiamo comunque
chiedendo a un astronauta di indossare
nello spazio una giacca piena di 22
litri d'acqua è vero che l'astronauta
nello spazio non si accorge del peso di
questa giacca però si accorge
sicuramente di doversi far carico di 22
kg in più quindi la sua massa inerziale
cosiddetta aumentata e quindi
l'astronauta deve imparare a muoversi in
questo ambiente accelerando e
decelerando per cui utilizzando forse
diverse per accelerare decelerare e
soprattutto qualcuno ci doveva dire se
questa giacca era davvero portabile e
indossabile se questa già cara tale da
non limitare i movimenti e anche e
soprattutto se era possibile riempirla
con l'acqua potabile della stazione
spaziale e poi svuotarla senza buttar
via l'acqua con la quale era stata
riempita perché chiaramente una risorsa
così non la possiamo certo sprecare
quindi l'intera idea si basa sulla
possibilità di utilizzare l'acqua in
emergenza per schermarsi e poi
recuperarla e renderla di nuovo
disponibile nel circuito dell'acqua di
bordo tutto questo c'è l'ha detto
fortunatamente con successo l'astronauta
italiano paolo nespoli che è stato da
pochissimo bordo della stazione spaziale
nel corso della sua ultima missione la
missione dita e paolo nespoli attestato
per noi la giacca di perseo
il tutto è successo in una giornata per
noi sicuramente molto particolare il 7
novembre 2017 e devo dirvi che tutto è
davvero andato per il meglio
oltre a dirvelo ho la fortuna di
potervelo mostrare direttamente quelle
immagini
la sezione sperimentale in orbita quello
che vi posso far vedere appunto che
paolo nespoli ha prima riempito la
giacca di perseo con l'acqua potabile
della stazione spaziale internazionale
quindi utilizzando 22 circa litri
d'acqua ha poi indossato la giacca
vedete nel video in alto a destra il
momento in cui paolo indossa la giacca
di perseo e dopo averla indossata si è
mosso all'interno della stazione della
stazione spaziale con questa giacca per
circa mezz'ora si è mosso per circa
mezz'ora ha effettuato tutte le attività
che un astronauta effettua o per cui è
veramente dimostrato che questa giacca è
indossabile per un utilizzo in comune
diciamo per effettuare tutti i possibili
interventi d'emergenza anche resi
necessari da una tempesta solare e
infine ha scaricato il contenuto di
questa giacca nel sistema di recupero di
acque di bordo e il tutto è successo
senza sprecare neanche una goccia
d'acqua quindi l'esperimento è stato
sicuramente un esperimento di successo
ora tornando all'introduzione letteraria
che mi sono permesso di fare è vero che
in questo caso non abbiamo chiesto a
nespoli di bere direttamente dalla sua
tuta è anche vero però che la stazione
spaziale internazionale con tutte le
scomodità del caso è sicuramente un
ambiente più accogliente meno ostile di
un pianeta desertico e popolato da vermi
giganti l'altra cosa molto vera però è
che in futuro pensiamo davvero di
chiedere qualcosa di simile agli
astronauti ovvero pensiamo che potranno
essere realizzati per gli sviluppi
futuri delle giacche come quella di
perseo o degli altri dispositivi come ad
esempio dei sacchi a pelo che possano
essere sia dei dispositivi di
immagazzinamento dell'acqua potabile sia
dei dispositivi dai quali gli astronauti
potranno effettivamente bere e che
questi dispositivi soprattutto possano
essere di protezione
dalla radiazione cosmica in particolare
dalle tempeste solari perché no proprio
in vista del prossimo viaggio speriamo
dell'uomo verso marte vi ringrazio
[Applauso]